il se passe toujours quelque chose sur
internet aux etats unis une femme a
accouché en direct sur le web grâce à
des caméras placées dans la salle de
travail moyennant finance les
internautes du monde entier ont donc pu
assister à la naissance du petit sean 3
kg 3 philippe gassot lui aussi un beau
bébé nous raconte cette première voici à
quoi ressemble le premier bébé internet
sa maman se prénomme elisabeth c'est
d'ailleurs tout ce que l'on saura d'aile
à 40 ans elle a accepté sur le réseau de
santé américain d'accoucher devant les
caméras reliées à internet
sa chambre à la clinique a été
spécialement aménagé ce sera donc une
naissance cybernétique la première de
tous les temps et cela devant 7 millions
d'amateurs d'internet qui ont accepté de
payer la mère qui a déjà trois enfants
c'est quand même posé pas mal de
questions ma modestie va en prendre un
coup
je ne serai pas ces coûts sera vu ou pas
vu et c'est ce qui m'inquiète le plus
mon correct les caméras se sont
détournés ou moment de la délivrance
si le diabète a donné naissance au petit
dernier dans un hôpital de floride en
public
c'est pour montrer à d'autres personnes
d'autres femmes
ce qu'est un accouchement le but était
on ne peut plus éducatif toute la
famille d'ailleurs étaient présentes
pendant le travail
si elle a été choisie il ya une semaine
c'est parce que ces accouchements été
rapide et qu'elle avait accepté de
déclencher celui là résultat un beau
bébé est une énorme promotion pour la
chaîne câblée america's health network
on ne dit rien des profits mais à 30
dollars soit 180 francs la connexion a
multiplié par 7 millions l'achat des
layettes n'est plus vraiment un problème